hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doki doki literature
club now we got to figure out who we're
gonna show our poem to first I don't
remember who we showed it to first last
time but I guess it doesn't matter let's
go to Monica at least Maria Monica hi
morp how's it going have you thought
about what you want to submit to perform
at the festival well being in this club
is one thing but performing in front of
a bunch of people I'll have to give it
some more thoughts okay no pressure but
whatever you do I'm sure it'll turn out
great
it would also make me happy to see okay
anyway let's take a look at today's poem
sure I'll let Monica take the poem I'm
holding in my hands all right I like
this one it makes me think of something
Sarah would like is that so you and say
are your really good friends right I
wouldn't be surprised if you had those
sort of things in common
oh well we may be good friends but say
Orry and I are actually really different
well that may be the case but maybe
there's also some similarities that you
wouldn't expect the way she talks about
you it sounds like the two of you really
care about each other's well-being even
if you show it in different ways
it ends up being more similar than you
think so I think that's the kind of vibe
I get when I read your poem hmm I didn't
write that you sure you're not reading
into it too much Monica could be yeah
could be oh gosh I sound like URI but
any case series writing is that kind of
gentle feel to it I can tell you she
likes exploring with emotions like
happiness and sadness who knew that
someone so happy would enjoy sad things
too yeah it's totally unexpected well
deets their own and you shouldn't be
afraid to experiment a little bit either
anyway I'll share my poem with you now
all right ah all right I wonder how this
is gonna go
the lady who knows everything an old
tailed cells of a lady who wanders earth
the lady who knows everything
a beautiful lady who's found every
answer all meaning all purpose and all
that was ever sought and here I am a
feather where'd my mouse a feather lost
a drift the sky victim of the currents
of the wind day after day I searched I
searched with little hope knowing
legends don't exist but when all else
has failed me when all others have
turned away the ledge
is all that remains the last dim star
glimmering in the twilight sky the twill
its guy until one day the wind ceases to
blow I fall and I fall and fall and fall
even more gentle as a feather a dry
quill expressionless but hand catches me
between the thumb and forefinger the
hand of a beautiful lady I look at her
eyes and find no end to her gaze the
lady who knows everything knows what I'm
thinking before I can speak she responds
in a hollow voice I have found every
answer all of which amount to nothing
there is no meaning there is no purpose
and we seek only the impossible I am NOT
your legend your legend does not exist
and with the breath she blows me back
afloat and I pick up a gust of wind okay
all right you know I feel like learning
and looking for answers are the sort of
things that give life meaning it not to
get too philosophical or anything but it
was kinda on my mind so that's what I
wrote about I see okey-dokey then I
never really put my thought into it in a
way it's almost paradoxical because even
if we had all the answers wouldn't the
world start to lose mists meaning one
thing I noticed seems like everyone in
the club prefers writing about things
that are more sad than happy how are you
surprised
I mean if everything was okay we
wouldn't really have anything to write
about would we humans are two aren't
two-dimensional creatures I think you'd
know that better than anyone you mean
one dimensional oh yeah that anyway
here's Monica's writing tip of the day
are you ever too shy to share your
writing because you're afraid it's not
that good it can be really disheartening
to get a lukewarm response to something
you put so much into but if you find
other people who enjoy writing then
sharing becomes a lot easier because
instead of just telling you what your
writing is good or go okay or bad
they'll want to focus more on everything
that went into it and the things you can
work on it's much more encouraging that
way and it'll make you want to continue
improving it's almost like having your
own little literature Club don't you
think that's my advice for you today
okay and considering that my response to
your poem may have been a little
lukewarm are you gonna go do something
about that you're gonna hold that
against me you're gonna be very angry at
me no no thanks for listening okay
all right who should I show my poem to
next well let's go straight to say Orry
this time hey say Orry
how you doing hmm it's nice I guess come
on I can already tell you don't like it
Thank You Siri just picked up on
something I said
is he you don't need to worry about what
I think after all you wrote this for
someone else didn't you probably Yuri
yeah I didn't write this for anyone
specifically maybe that's not really
what I meant though but it's okay you're
making new friends just like I was
hoping that makes me really happy and
you're happy too right in this club well
of course I am good that's all that
matters to me I feel like there should
be something else that matters to you
say Orry also considering I picked this
poem to be for you say Orry is there
something wrong ah no nothing I'm just a
little tired today Hey
alright just tell me if you need
anything I will don't worry about me
okay you can go play with everyone else
now if you insist I'll go play yeah
that's what we're doing I'm gonna go
home a little bit early today see you
worried tell Monica I wasn't feeling
well okay I'll see you tomorrow before I
can say anything else see Rory
cheerfully walks out of the classroom
humming to herself that's that's a
little weird huh peculiar
Natsuki hello this one's alright alright
no one liked my poem well yeah it
doesn't blow me away but there's nothing
really I hate about it it's just not
really my style I mean that's fine come
to think of it this reminds me of say
orys poems from yesterday yeah you think
so
yeah well I guess have you been friends
with her for so long you might be on the
same wavelength but you never really
struck me as her type Siri has a type
all of a sudden oh I don't know but
honestly how can someone so fluffy spend
so much time with someone like you it's
like she's dragging around a dead weight
well a thank you thank you for that well
it was a little unnecessary but I think
of it this way if it weren't for me she
probably would just fly away like
letting go above
you could say we each take care of each
other in our own way
whatever it is I don't get it oh yeah I
guess I'm supposed to show you my poem
here yeah sure okay thanks for the
insult I'll be your Beach your mind is
so full of troubles and fears that
diminished your wonder over the years
but today I have a special place a beach
for us to go ashore reaching beyond your
sight a sea that sparkles with brilliant
light the walls in your mind will melt
away before the sunny glow I'll be the
beats that washes your worries away I'll
be the beats that your daydream about
each day oh I'll be the beats that makes
your heart leap in a way you thought had
left you long ago let's bury your heavy
thoughts in a pile of sand bathed in
sunbeams and hold my hand wash your
insecurities in the salty sea and let me
see you shine let's leave your memories
in a footprint trail set you free and my
windy sail and remember the reasons
you're wonderful when you press your
lips to mine oh I'll be the beats that
washes your worries away I'll be the
beats that you daydream about each day
I'll be the beats that makes your heart
leap in a way fun you'd left long ago
but if you let me by your side your own
Beach your own escape you're learning to
love yourself again this beautiful yeah
I felt like I kept writing about
negative things so I wanted to write
something with a nice message for once
besides the beach is awesome kind of
hard to write anything negative about
the beach so you decided to write about
the beach first and then came up with
the message later yeah well it's only
because of what happened yesterday
I mean after URI and I realized we kind
of wrote about the same thing she wanted
to pick a topic and have us both write
about it or whatever oh you really can
see her doing that huh making us write
about a simple topic than trying to
impress me by coming up with something
all fancy well it's not like I care I
just did it anyway I mean I guess mine
ended up being kind of metaphorical too
but there's nothing wrong with doing
that once in a while at the very least
it was good practice Natsuki I don't
have a goddamn idea what you yammering
on about I mean if you have something
that you got a problem with just come
on-site
alright fine then bye all right you all
ready hello how are you a well done morp
oh no no you've definitely improved your
writing over the course of these few
days Thanks pick blot of random words
out of a hat sure worked out well for me
as my advice been helpful to you know
yeah definitely I'm glad sharing our
writing like this it's a lot more fun
and rewarding than I anticipated
I'll need to remember that thank Monica
I think we all felt a little awkward at
first but now it seems like everyone is
enjoying sharing their writing and
seeing what others think I guess I can't
really disagree I was afraid this whole
thing would be a chore but he's a great
way for me to spend some personal time
with all the girls in the club but it's
been fun to get in knowing everyone in
their writing but I guess doing some
writing myself if you call throwing
darts at words on a wall writing but
that's just my creative process baby
well have you learned anything about
yourself more nope not a thing I'm a
blank slate I'm totally empty inside
well you know how I'd like to say that
writing is a very personal way to get in
touch with yourself I don't remember you
ever saying that in the end it doesn't
matter if you're a good writer or a bad
writer and even my opinions are just my
opinions you know as always I believe
what's most important is exploring and
discovering yourself that's comforting
because I have a funny feeling your your
desires are a little off-putting I'm
kind of afraid of disappointing you in
some other way yeah why me
well you're always sophisticated with
your writing and have the most advice to
share oh is that so and so and lust URI
thinks for a good minute that must be
terrible yeah for me to have become
someone whose opinion is fearsome how
unlikable of me you'll be it's not as
bad as you're making out sound in your
head I mean it's really bad but not that
bad
I just mean that I respect your opinion
I see I'm sorry that I always overthink
and come to those sorts of conclusions
I'm just a little too used to it
overthinking it being disliked oh you're
a what what am I saying I'm sorry I
didn't mean to bring that up
god it's so hard being a tall beautiful
anime girl oh god why why have I been
cursed with these qualities let's move
on alright do you want to share your
poem now okay here
here we are Beach a Marvel millions of
years in the making with a womb of Earth
chaotically meet specific under clear mu
sky an expanse of bliss
but beneath Garay rolling clouds in
endless enigma the easiest world to get
lost in is one where everything can be
found one can only build a sand castle
where the sand is wet but where the sand
is wet the tide comes will it gently
look at your foundations until you give
in will its sudden wave send you
crashing down in the blink of an eye
either way the outcome is the same yet
still we build sandcastles I stand with
a firmer wraps around my ankles where my
toes squish into the sand the salty
Aerith therapeutic the breeze is gentle
yet powerful I sink my toes into the
ultimate boundary line tempted by the
foamy ten Devils turn back and I
abandoned my piece to a road to shore
the lift forward and I returned to the
earth forevermore
ah beautiful beautiful um I'm aware that
the beach is kind of an inane thing to
write about what's wrong with the beach
you got a problem with the beach lady I
got prom with you if you got a problem
with the beach although the beach is
close to the ocean before I now suddenly
have a problem with the beach and I
wanted to die but I did my best to make
a metaphorical approach to it yeah
Natsuki already told me about it she
she'd added she didn't say anything
weird did she she just wanted us to
write about the same topic again I
supposed to better compare the
differences in our writing styles our
thought processes yeah probably
anyway it was her idea not mine knowing
her it's no surprise that she wants to
do something like that he probably just
wants to show off it's not like I have a
particular interest in a writing style
it's just I went with her a request like
a friend
but well I suppose it's not so bad to
write about something simple on occasion
it can be refreshing you know it's good
for me to calm my thoughts once in a
while yeah I think I agree even though
it's kind of crazy and you're kind of
worried about what everyone thinks about
you too much thanks for sharing all
right hi Monica okay you three we're all
done sharing poems right why don't you
start figuring out hold on a second is
it just me or did you say something
strangest now yeah something did sound a
bit unusual that's right you deviated
from your usual catchphrase when
addressing the club catchphrase I don't
have a catchphrase geez why is it mood
so weird today look even Yuri is an
immune to it stagnating air is common
for shadowing that's something terrible
is aminute hey wait what's happening in
your books maybe look the only things
different is that C or E isn't here ah
it seems you're right sigh saiary always
helps lighten the mood a little bit
doesn't she it's almost like everyone's
bounces off thrown off a little when
she's not around what the heck did you
run off to anyway I thought she just
went to pee Natsuki please show some
decency well come on everybody pees she
actually wasn't feeling too well him
went home early is that so hope she's
alright
seriously all the times did not go home
with her you picked the time she's not
feeling well so much for you two being
old don't be No first of all stop
misunderstanding my friendship and only
friendship just friends with say Orry
and second we're just friends
she's kind of been avoiding me today so
I didn't want to force it that curious
expression coming from Yuri of all
people calm down guys I talked to her
earlier and everything is fine what did
she say anyway we need anyway forget
what you said more didn't you you don't
matter I'm manipulating things by the
scene apparently anyway we need to
figure out the rest of the festival
preparations so let's decide what
everyone will be doing this weekend I
already know what I'm doing what are you
doing that's right that's who he will be
making cupcakes ah okay but we need a
lot of thumbs in different flavors can
you handle all those by yourself
Sukie challenge accepted and so for
myself I'm gonna be printing and
assembling all the poetry pamphlets CRE
will be helping me design them and as
for your as for URI your you can yeah
yeah guys can you help me come up with
something for URI
I'm you oh I didn't mean for that
to come true
okay no that's not it at all you're the
most talented person here you know
now now Natsuki spouting - she say even
I can tell now I guess I never gave CRE
enough credit but I can tell things are
even harder when on you when she's not
around ah
that may be the case but if I can't also
be a leader on my own then I won't grow
as a person
so URI you have beautiful handwriting
you know so you should make some banners
and decorations to help set the
atmosphere atmosphere I'm about that I I
love this beer Yuri's expression
suddenly changes if she stares at the
desk and focus it starts nodding to
herself your mind is already racing I
see that's great
you'll be a wonderful help Yuri but
anyway that just leaves you more yeah
the one who is truly useless I accept my
useless nature I will go on my way and
do absolutely nothing because anything
that I would do would be a detriment to
your wonderful Club haha don't say that
in fact both Natsuki and Yuri have some
pretty heavy tasks to handle it would
probably go a long way to give one of
them a hand
you could always help me out as well it
would really appreciative of that ah
that's his Monika suggesting I spent the
weekend with one of my club members yeah
how on earth are they gonna respond to
his suggestion like that oh I suppose I
wouldn't mind a bit of help oh don't
mind if I do yeah well even if you don't
know how to bake there's always some
dirty work I could give you it's not
like Monica's going to give me a choice
and you shouldn't be sitting on your
butt anyway Natsuki tries to mumble a
bunch of excuses like that um if I
recall Natsuki you mentioned that you
would like to handle
making on your own Mort may not like to
be around if all you only make him out
to be a nuisance so therefore he may be
more suited to assisting with the
decorations by my side where our thumbs
can be so close hold on I never said
that hard could it be to make a few
decorations anyway she's stupid idiot
sounds more like it's just making an
excuse if for more - what are you saying
it would be extremely meticulous work
and baking isn't just what do you think
guys guys guys shut the F up please
alright God let's settle down for a
moment in the end I think it's up to
morph to decide how he'd like to
contribute besides isn't really unjust
friends in Germany I like the way you
lean I like the way you lean Montag I
like the way you lean alright anyway so
I'm sure he's interested in you
literally just said I'm surprised as
well sorry sorry I was just saying
though
jeez can we just settle this already
yeah morp you're okay with this right Oh
ladies ladies bears there's more Pannell
for everybody just everyone calm down
here a little bit more powder three
three ladies yeah in the end it's up to
you ah of course it's very well in that
case everyone looks straight at me see
but of course I'm gonna go with C or E
[Music]
do you do you
[Applause]
woo-ha
okay so here's my logic right Natsuki
Yuri and Monika are all taking care of
something
here or other say Orie something's
obviously bothering say Orie but also
this is the first time I've been able to
spend any sort of free time with Monika
and there's something about Monica the
way her green eyes are creeping over
that the bad name bar that just you know
sets my heart of fluttering you know how
it'd be you guys know how it is right
you guys understand what I'm talking
about right right you don't okay all
right then well if you do understand
what I'm talking about you know all
right
anyway I saved I'm gonna go with Monica
I know say orys probably needs to be by
her side right now but what whatever
Monica
well I guess I should probably be
helping Monica yeah you picked me hold
on one second yeah Monica you're the one
who needs the least help out of all of
us but I agree with netsuke not only is
your work already most suitable for one
person but you already have C or E as
well but Nora was the one who ah it
doesn't matter
Morfitt doesn't matter you were the one
who scared him into picking you in the
first place
he's a club president Monica you're
supposed to be responsible decision for
the club Monica you shouldn't let any
ulterior motives interfere with his
decision
well terior motives what are you saying
URI in fact it sounded like you guys are
the one who with auntie really uncertain
you motives otherwise this wouldn't have
been made into such a big deal the first
blaze that's completely false Monica
yeah we have a lot of work to do you
know we won't do as good a job if you
make us work alone ah maybe that's true
think of the club Monica if we want our
event to succeed that we need to
appropriately distribute our resources
ah so are you gonna do the right thing
president okay okay I get it
huh it's technically most logical form
or tail point of you two so I guess
that's what we'll do what that's
then okay
a load of garbage what a load of big
flip-flapping garbage I'm gonna go with
C or E then you stupid idiots I mean if
it's gonna be anyone then I'd prefer
helping say Orry I mean we're already
neighbors and Lamonica c'est Mon
existence Yuri was helping her geez
do you really hate us that much yep yep
yes I do
yeah sorry I didn't mean for this to be
difficult yeah Monica
oh sure you didn't oh yeah okay just
think of the club okay that is
it's it's you're
oh this is
it's
well I'm gonna go back go back
i'ma see both of these moot choices and
I'll see if I just want to see if
they're moot choices like if I pick say
over here I mean if it's gonna be a C or
E we're already neighbors but Monica
said wait what oh it's the same thing
god dammit well alright then Oh God why
do I have to pick one of you it
I don't care about gonna do kick URI new
Dukey URI alright you know what
you screw you guys I'm gonna flip a coin
cuz I don't have one preference either
way which way for one of you two I don't
care where's a goddamn coin give me a
coin give me a coin Murch plug I've got
this special Christmas edition dog toy
for chica it's got chicas face on it if
it lands face-up
I'm gonna go Natsuki if it lands
facedown I'm going with ma yurid
here we go
hey it's Natsuki all right there we are
it's just random chance cuz I just don't
care
it can't be bothered this the
Natsuki
well baking sounds like it could be fun
and you guys made it sound like a lot of
work so it probably could use two people
don't worry
baking is a ton of fun you'll definitely
agree just a minute ago you were saying
that do that's because you're never just
going to do it more
oh nevermind okay well anyway you'll be
fine by yourself right URI of course all
alone with my poems and books I'm used
to it after all being a band want a
stick-in-the-mud
that's good even though URIs being
melodramatic it's a little hardened to
not feel bad so that's everything right
anything else we need to talk about no I
think that's it are you guys excited
nope no I'm not I am NOT I am NOT this
is not what I wanted everything except
the performance is gonna be awesome
okay cool I don't think really I don't
really think that counts what about you
morp me I guess you could say I'm
interested to see how it'll turn out
that's good enough for me what about you
URI yo D she's still sulking
she's dead inside just like everybody
else is gonna be dead on the outside
alright now Sookie start spouting - it's
not I mean it's not that big a deal or
anything well it might not be just that
I think the URI might just be feeling a
little unappreciated in general having
to come up with something for her to do
and then nobody offering to help that
doesn't mean that Sookie glances back
and forth between everyone with a
worried expression look now Sookie goes
over and puts her hand down on your
shoulders you worry you really are the
most talented one here and and you're
gonna help make the event a lot more fun
and welcoming I mean the cupcakes will
probably help a lot too well you're
gonna make the atmosphere special
that'll be really important for the way
that people feel during the performances
so you need to stop being dumb you need
to stop being as stupid
idiot a big dumb goofy ugly idiot give
yourself a little more credit Natsuki
releases her hands and turns around to
face the other direction you didn't
really mean that did you all the
screaming about how dumb I was you
didn't mean that did you cuz that hurt
my feelings
oh not really but your reason the only
one surprised Monica and I are also
taken aback by not Sookie's words
Natsuki of all people to be saying such
encouraging things but I begin to
understand and fall in love Natsuki was
trying to sound like say Orie even if it
didn't work perfectly I tell this she
tried to say something Siri what say at
a time like this
because see Ori always helps everyone
smile and feel good about themselves
I'm sorry for being a big stinky stupid
idiot I'm gonna do my bestest and all of
us are gonna make a really great event
yeah I hope to see everyone do their
best but with that there's nothing more
for today so I guess it's our time for
Ezra to head out okay but I'm staying
here a bit longer I barely got to do any
reading today so fair enough there's
nothing wrong with that
everyone bags up their things I start to
follow Monika and Yuri out the door as
they chat between each other um where
are you going
we still need to figure out our plans
for this weekend you literally would
have gotten home and realized that you
didn't even have a way to contact me oh
that's true right okay I have no idea
how that slipped my mind maybe because I
just didn't care
geez good thing I stopped you you big
dumb idiot I'm giving you my number
okay do it amazing I'm able to predict
the following dialog why would I do that
know that Sookie gives me her number
okay coming over on Sunday I'll bring
all your groove
wait you're coming to my house yeah
what's wrong with that I mean I just
figured that since I'm the one helping I
would be going to your house Yeah right
creepy weirdo guy over at my house like
dad would kill me really it's kind of
strict if you ask me yeah how do you
think I feel I can't do anything with
Ione anyway I just need to complain for
a second we have each other's numbers
now that's all I needed from you and
nothing else do you go eff off
no see you on Sunday okay so I'll text
you when I'm coming over I find I mean
yeah I'm really gonna show you why I
love oh well I'm gonna show you why I
love bacon so let's go oh I've gotta
show you what you're gonna see wood
you'll have a seat so good so you better
look forward to it oh yeah Oh didn't you
say you were just gonna give me the
dirty work oh I'll give you the dirty
work all right well I was just saying
that no like I could act like in front
of everyone that's that I was looking
forward to this wait really well kind of
just because I never got to bake with
someone else before that's always who
ready good sorry for overreacting anyway
I'll be heading out now see you on
Sunday
never mind
All Right see ya okay I can't believe
this
Natsuki is gonna be coming to my house
on Sunday even though I would have
preferred to do this with say Yuri my
anxiety still shoots through the roof I
guess I've gotten pretty used to
handling her at this point but who knows
what end might end up happening when
we're outside of school she even told me
she was looking forward to it maybe
we're going to kiss in whatever I shake
my head oh god I shouldn't think such
naughty thoughts why do I feel nervous
him see or he finds out about this it's
not like we feel that way about each
other besides like Monica said this is
about the club I have nothing to worry
about if I just go with it then I'll
have a good time
if I just go with it okay it's already
Sunday wow that was fast okay wait hang
on
go save it's already Sunday I've been
getting increasingly anxious about not
Sookie's upcoming visit I keep telling
myself there's no reason to be
servus but he doesn't help much they
wonder if she'll act any different when
they're just the two of us hoagies
meanwhile she's been texting me a lot we
sent each other one after exchanging
numbers to double-check but it turned
into a conversation she's almost a
different personality on the phone using
tons of emoji and cute language she also
really likes complaining about things
but I saw that one coming
putting noose Natsuki aside I haven't
heard a thing from Sears since she left
club early that other day sound like we
text each other all the time or anything
but I've been worried about her in the
back of my mind between once a or he
said and what Monica said is really okay
for me to put serious feelings aside
when she might need me probably not I
decide to visit say all right before
Natsuki comes over rather than asking I
simply tell her I'm coming over much
like we've done in the past once I reach
Sara's house I knock on the door before
entering in myself again we used to play
I got a bad feeling about this play so
often that we made it a habit of simply
entering each other's houses like we're
family
got a bad feeling about this the house
is quiet CRE isn't anywhere on the first
floor so I assume she's up in a room
it's already strange of her not to run
down and greet me head up to her bedroom
when I finally mean find her C or e oh
hi mom I sit down in a room CRE forces a
smile but it's easy to tell that she's
different there's a minute of silence
between us
you haven't come over like this in a
long time have you ah I guess you're
right it's been a long time not much has
really changed has it
series room is as messy as it's always
been I also recognize the same stuffed
animals in wall decorations that she's
had for years now hey if you came over
more often it wouldn't be such a mess
that's because I end up cleaning it up
for you how come he suddenly wanted to
come over today are you supposed to see
that Sookie today yeah but wait how did
you know that saiary had already left by
the time we decided that last meeting
Monica told me it's only natural for her
to keep me informed about the festival
preparations right that's true
maybe but what about you aren't you
going to be helping Monica today of
course but I'm just helping your online
we didn't plan to meet up or anything ah
so it's just me and Mitsuki then right
yeparooni
is more silence between us series stares
in a random direction everything about
it behavior is really uncharacteristic
I'm finally getting the point I just
wanted to see how her you were doing
after you left on Friday when
something's wrong you can't hide it from
me I know you too well
Co Jerry smile shaking her head that's
no good more why can't it just be like
it's always been this is all my fault if
I didn't get so weak and accidentally
express my feelings if I didn't make
that stupid mistake then you wouldn't
have been worried about me at all you
wouldn't have come here you wouldn't
have haven't even been thinking about me
right now but this is this my punishment
isn't it I'm getting punished for being
so selfish I think that's why the world
decided to have you come over today it
just wants to torture me he okay say
Orie that's not funny at all at all hmm
I grabbed Sayuri by the shoulders a
shaker really hard what on earth are you
saying
are you listening yourself right now
I know something happened to you there's
no other explanation for you to be like
this
so tell me already
until I know I won't be able to stop
thinking about it
ah ha ha ha stop shaking me Sara gives
me an empty smile you really put me in a
trap more but you're wrong nothing
happened to me I've always been like
this
you're just seeing it for the first time
seeing what what are you talking about C
or E you're really just gonna make me
say it aren't you more I guess I have no
choice this time the thing is I've had
really bad depression my whole life did
you know that why do you think I'm late
to school every day because most days I
can't even find a reason to get out of
bed what reason is there to do anything
when I fully know how worthless I am why
go to school why eat why make friends
why make other people put their energy
and caring to waste by having them spend
it on me that's what it feels like and
that's why I just want to make everyone
happy
without anyone worrying about me
jeez I'm in shock I can't even figure
out how to respond how is it possible
that Siri kept this from me the entire
time that I've known her did you really
want so bad for me to just not think
about her Y C or e yeah why is it that
you've never told me about this it
almost feels like I've been betrayed
it's your close friend because if I knew
I would have done everything I could to
support you even if there's only so much
that I could do I would have tried a
little bit harder to make every day a
little better for you that's why I'm
your friend all you had to do is tell me
you don't understand it all more why do
you think I didn't tell you because if I
told you then you would have to waste
effort caring about me instead of doing
important things I don't want to be
cared about it's bittersweet when people
try to care about me feels nice
sometimes but it also feels like a bat
being swung against my head
that's why I wanted so badly for you to
make friends with everyone else helping
everyone be happy together is the best
thing for me but then I discovered
something else too seeing you make
friends and get closer with everyone in
the club
feels like a spear going through my
heart so that's why that's why I decided
the world just wants to torture me
every path leads to nothing but hurt
you're right that I don't understand I
don't understand your feelings at all
say Dori but I don't need to understand
whatever it is whatever it takes for me
to help you stop hurting that's what
I'll do no more there's nothing nothing
at all
the only thing that could have helped is
if everything could be like it always
was but I was selfish I finally showed
you what a horrible person I am
tears streak down series face
I made you join the literature club
because I was selfish and I was punished
by my heart hurting in a way that I
couldn't understand and now you came
here and I made you hurt too I'm just
weak and selfish that's all I am so
that's crazy thinking that's why I'm
going to accept these punishments
because I deserve every last one oh
that's ridiculous
without thinking I once again grab
sailors shoulders this time I pull her
into a tight embrace ah
[Music]
morp say Yuri I don't care if you feel
selfish I'm really happy that you
convinced me to join the club seeing you
every day makes it worthwhile enough if
I make friends with everyone else then
that's just a bonus but please never
underestimate how much I care about you
I wouldn't have it any other way
say Ori isn't hugging me back despite my
arms being wrapped around her seryozha
arms remain undersides
she starts sobbing next to my ear no
don't do this to me
please don't do this morp I see Ori
barely manages to speak between her sobs
I don't know if I'm doing the right
thing but all I want is for her to know
that I care
if you have it in you to call yourself
selfish then you have to let me be
selfish too no matter what it takes I'll
figure out what needs to change I'll
make these feelings go away and if
there's anything that you need me to do
then you'd better tell me I'll get mad
if you don't I don't know I don't know I
don't know gently say or he finally puts
her arms around me in return
I don't know anything it's all really
scary I don't understand any of my
feelings more the only time I'm not
feeling nothing is when I'm feeling
pained but your hugs are so warm and
that's really scary to say or let's me
go as she does so I let her go as well
the festival's tomorrow yeah it's gonna
be fun right
yeah how would you like for me to spend
it all with you um ah it's what I want I
promise hey I think that would be nice
then yeah
savory wipes your eyes if I could spend
the whole day here I would of all days
this has to be the one where I have
other plans maybe I should cancel no
don't please don't if you did that then
I really wouldn't forgive you but it's
almost time for netsuke to meet me in my
house but they're very lease do you want
to come along and help out it would be
fun to my surprise Sarah shakes her head
I'm sorry I don't know if that would be
very good for me today you understand
right ah it's kind of hard for me to
fully understand but I'm trying my
hardest it's okay don't worry too much
about it I'll see you tomorrow okay all
right I look forward to it I would like
if this was me I would have canceled
plans right then and spend it all with
salary like it doesn't even matter if
like I'm in love or nothing it's just
like god that's what a friend would do
one friend should do just forget plans
Natsuki would understand Sarah's the one
that needs on the way home I find myself
still feeling uneasy but if it's hard
for me to keep thinking about it when
Natsuki is about to come over to
I think saiary is right i shouldn't be
worrying too much and we're definitely
gonna have a great time tomorrow i
should just focus on what's ahead of me
I don't know I don't know I just feel
bad about it
I spent only a few minutes back home
anxiously awaiting that Sookie's arrival
before I know she texts me to let me
know she's outside the front door
without delay I opened the front door
and let her in hey I don't know what I
was expecting but seeing that Sookie in
something other than her school uniforms
totally threw me off seeing her in such
cute clothes make the uniform seem
totally unfitting in comparison geez
don't make it feel so awkward already
stop staring at my clothes it's gonna be
a long afternoon so don't just be weird
just because you're not used to seeing
me outside of school
anyway I'm coming in I see you brought a
lot of stuff now Sookie is carrying a
large bag that it's probably full of
baking supplies well I didn't want to
come all this way to find out that your
kitchen isn't equipped for the job so
I'm moving and you brought everything I
asked yeah I did yesterday now Sookie
asked me to buy a bunch of ingredients
if I didn't already have them at home
glad I could count on you to do your
part well I am mr. reliable
I'm surprised here and then Sookie
suddenly say that rather than something
snarky like she usually does could it be
that she's a little different outside
school after all anyway let's go to the
kitchen what you're not even gonna offer
to take this heavy bag for me where's
your hospitality more come on since when
did I need to be a gentleman
I grabbed the bag Natsuki holds out to
me dread is ridiculously heavy I carried
that all the way here are you impressed
I see now I didn't know that you were so
strong yeah I am impressed Natsuki seems
like I always underestimate you and your
strong body okay it's because I'm so
small isn't it
you jerk that's who he hits a fist into
my chest I go flying into the wall and
break three of my ribs Hey
besides there's nothing to do sighs has
nothing to do with it not Sookie you
really hate being small that much um
it's not like I hate it I mean sometimes
I like proving people wrong when they
only think I'm worth my sighs it's fun
when I get to be small and also better
than both her people hey Phyllis a way
Sukie morph read you loud and clear on
that one but geez never mind what are
you making me say don't think you can
make me talk about weird things just
because we're not at school
are we getting started or what there's a
lot of stuff I got to teach you haha
what that's a little bit more like you
you're more fun when you just speak your
mind like that hey now you're treating
me like a kid I was just trying to be a
little nicer nope it's just because I
don't have a mature and sexy figure like
Yuri doesn't mean you should treat me
like that Sookie catches her words in
her face turns red
Natsuki how dare you mention Yuri's tall
and sexy body forget it
I didn't say anything I should apologize
yeah I appreciate that you were trying
to be nicer I should have been a little
bit more considerate but also if that's
what you're thinking then you should
know that there are tons of guys who are
into body types like yours now this
conversation is suddenly taking a weird
turn how would you know that anyway just
try judge me trust more partners one hmm
anyway gross hey what's that to me
who else man let's just get started
already
oh the sexual tension is genital second
air haha
you get all sour when girls call you
gross I finally found your weakness morp
that's who you've smiles deviously
please spare me
I left none so you decided to dish out
more insults like that there's no way
I'm not fighting back what she's
satisfied enough for now finally
starting to pull things out of her bag
so we can get started okay before long
the whole kitchen is a mess
spoons dirty bowls flour spilled food
and plastic bags are strewn about every
countertop the mixer isn't big enough to
make all the batter at once so we had to
do it several times meanwhile and that
Sookie's babysitting all my movements to
make sure I don't mess up her precious
baking more boy didn't you put the food
coloring the batter is going in the oven
soon so I need to fill the trays I think
it's still in the bag next to the table
what are you using for the color the
batter of course I'm making each tray a
little different color that way even if
the flavors aren't different everyone
can still pick their favorite it's a
cute idea
you're cute it's cute idea cutie are we
doing
anything like that with the eye thing do
you want to ah you're asking me I don't
really have any preference so come on
you're not putting any heart into this
can't you at least try to have fun I'm
having fun baking I'm not really true
what did Sookie is trying to get out of
me meanwhile I see her separate the
batter into smaller bowls and put a few
drops of food coloring in each it does
look pretty cool
see it's not like baking is just about
following instructions the president
safety is where you get to be great I
have the most fun a few million times
more worth in the end is looking at me
everyone lighting up like the ones he
made in the first day huh I recall
Natsuki proudly presenting her cat
shaped cupcakes and CRA and Monica's
delighted expressions I wonder if I
could make Natsuki proud like that too
yeah maybe I will use food coloring then
it sounds like you're starting to
understand you starting to get it huh
just make sure you completely finish
mixing the icing before you mess with
the food coloring yeah it's getting
there we were just using an electric
mixer for the batter so I got stuck with
a whisk and a huge bowl don't worry
morp got mixing on lock got my speeds
one and a million it's all good yeah the
icing still all lumpy are you even
trying well yeah I'll just take a little
longer see I'll be here all night if you
do it like that
here look grabs a whisk and uses her
other hand to tilt the bowl back you
need to really need to beat the
ever-loving out of this after a few
seconds the consistency of the icing has
already improved see your dumb idiot as
if to emphasize Natsuki sticks a finger
in the icing and pops in in her mouth I
reluctantly start to do the same hey let
Sookie suddenly grabs my wrist
I don't want your gross fingers in my
icing your icing a you forgetting who
did all the work I start to fight back
trying to inch my finger towards the
bowl they'll make me beat the crap out
of you next I'd like to see you try that
slosh I just sprayer with a whole bowl
of icing I push harder just enough for
my featured finger to reach the icing I
triumphantly scoop some with my finger
just as Natsuki tugs with all their
might
the force of net Sookie's pulling caused
me to stumble making her stumble in turn
we fall on each other probably gross you
got it on my foot you got it on my face
whose fault is that there's a big glob
of icing on that Sookie's cheek she
tries to reach it with her tongue but
it's too far away
geez you know what take this Natsuki
instead wipes it off with her finger
before shoving her finger towards my own
face yeah wish I'm faster I grab a risk
with my hand before it reaches my face I
don't like this conversation I just
don't like it
Natsuki tries to reuse her other hand to
fight back but I grab with that one as
well
wrassle frassle ahahaha stop haha not
until you apologize for calling me
growth hahahaha yeah fine fine I'm sorry
for calling you gross you know I don't
mean it it's just fun seeing you react
to it you do that to me all the time you
know saying dumb things just to get a
reaction out of me
you really shouldn't tease girls like
that is that so in that case I probably
shouldn't do this either I take Natsuki
finger and put it in my mouth licking
off the icing woo woo that's me he's so
surprised that she can't even figure out
how to get mad at me her face is
entirely red more you really shouldn't
do that kind of things to girls unless
you really like them you know that right
[Music]
oh the moon turn to this so quickly so
quickly I've been uncomfortable for the
past five minutes everybody in the
comments hiding behind their pillows bad
alright
Oh Natsuki gazes at me in silence I
notice her shallow I didn't think that
word was breaths there for a second why
am i starting to feel dizzy
yeah hey I don't know where the fire
alarm starts going off now Sookie rushes
over to the oven something burning I
thought you didn't put the cupcakes in
yet oh no wonder you left a dirty train
here dummy how could you make a mistake
like that you're finished you pulled out
guns and shoots me right there in there
you should have checked before turning
the oven on idiot don't blame me for
your mistakes dummy
jeez now Sookie uses an oven mitt grab
the blackened tray out of the oven she
sets it on top of the stove in another a
moment the fire alarm stops you're
anyway I'm putting them in the oven now
yeah the tension from the moment before
still lingers over our heads but the
moment has already been lost now watch
this and the Sookie slides the cupcake
trays into the oven then I reluctantly
pick up the whisk and continue with the
icing like nothing ever happened
cuz nothing did ah that smells so good
the cupcakes are already being ready to
be pulled out of the oven as soon as the
Sookie opens the oven door a blast of
sweet-smelling warm air fills the room
look at how cute they all look she
proudly shows off the different colored
cupcakes in each of the tres
they'll look even better once we add the
icing not like you need me to tell you
that to tell me that it's I brought
decorating stuff so I hope we can get
creative no don't do that
I've heard warnings about getting
creative here scoop the icing into these
bags now see if he hands me some plastic
bags I have these nozzles that will make
it look nice and fluffy this one can
even make flowers we probably won't be
using it this time though so I don't
even know why I mentioned it what's this
one for
I pick up one of the nozzles that has a
much thinner tip than the others that
one's really thin you know why that one
is but you can also use it to write
stuff on a cake like happy barb day for
whatever ah I see
okay that gives me an idea actually all
right well it's a literature event right
we can make it a little more literature
themed by writing a different word on
each of the cupcakes it would be fun to
see people choose their cupcake based on
a word that
like mmm I was kind of expecting you to
say something really stupid and then you
did that's actually a really cute idea
so maybe I'm getting it from you which
boot you mean I'm not cute ooh
come on we're not at school nobody's
judging you can't dress an act like this
and not expect me to think you're cute
well not Sookie's voice trails off same
with you cutie huh did you say something
no nothing
let's just do the icing then Sookie
picks up the pace and fastens the nozzle
on each of the bags there's a lot to do
so we shouldn't be wasting time here
I'll show you how to do it and then go
Stiles right behind me just like like
the unlike thought the wheel of clay
without giving me a chance to think
about it Anna Sookie quickly moves on
she shows me how to apply the icing and
then we each get to work I wrote
butthole on one just in case someone's
favorite word is butthole you never know
aardvark for people who enjoy the
beginning of the dictionary
you know Oh markiplier for people that
don't want a cupcake when we're finally
finished netsuke puts them all side by
side to admire our work look at how
pretty they are together look at how
pretty we are together
yeah they're there aren't they I wish I
could have one now
well there's no reason you can right I
don't see any harm in that
oh yeah but my dad's making dinner
tonight so I really need to save my
appetite uh-huh Sarah is the exact
opposite in that regard if she was here
she'd probably be down ten cupcakes
already and she would still eat dinner
come on that's just unhealthy besides
well my dad cooks and he'd eat as much
of his as a can well anyway I was hoping
we would have time for manga but I need
to be home for dinner already that's a
shame it's your fault for working so
slowly you should have thought about
that it's not like you'll always have
this chance what what are you talking
about man
as usual ended Sookie places the blame
on me you can bring the cupcakes
tomorrow right if you and Sarah each
carry something you probably do it in
one trip
yeah I can do that don't worry I won't
let her eat any wink ahaha I wish you
would listen to me the way she listens
to you ah yeah I think again back to the
conversation I had with sori Ori
earlier today I felt so helpless CRE
always does listen to me but at that
point it feels like she couldn't listen
to me at all
okay I backed up good work today you go
I'll walk you out a gas balloon just
like that in Sookie's about really feels
like the afternoon went by in a flash
more than that did I even take the
opportunity to get closer to her like I
wanted well I guess I'll be off then
thanks for all the help and everything
see you tomorrow
wait Natsuki yeah what you said before
about not always having this chance
doesn't have to be that way oh and
funded here you showed me how fun baking
could be like you wanted aside from that
you can come over anytime okay I think
that if possible I'd like to spend more
time like this if you want to read manga
or go out somewhere
oh do you really mean that
Natsuki looks at me tensely like she's
trying to hide her expression yeah I
want to spend more time with you baby
more I can totally forget how ridiculous
morp is I thought you only cared about
getting this done whoa I'm sorry I had
to leave so early today
I really didn't want to I would really
stay here longer if I could I feel the
same way as you so oh whoa hey whoa hey
whoa hey on a second here hey whoa hey
whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa wait Sookie
standing inches from me Natsuki looks up
at me I feel her fingers gently clutch
at the sides of my shirt as if holding
onto me her rose-colored cheeks and
matching eyes fill my vision why does
she have rose eyes by the way that's
weird
along with her slightly parted lips what
is happening my head starts to go dizzy
as I feel her soft breath
this is against me I felt it for a while
that Sookie suddenly jumps back say Yuri
ah hi more say Ori just now we weren't
well you should have come a little
earlier I'm already on my way out so oh
really that's too bad
yeah well I'll still see you at the
festival tomorrow so it's fine
just don't eat any cupcakes before then
anyway later clearly flustered Natsuki
hurries off in cieariy waves goodbye say
Yuri
I thought you didn't want to come over
today oh well you know I have terrible
timing so you know I decided we're at
Ryde stay in my room but I my
imagination was really being mean to me
so I had to come by her and see it for
myself see what what are you talking
about you know how much fun you were
having with that Sookie and that clothes
you got to her makes me day you've made
such good friends that's all that
matters to me oh geez tears start
falling down syrupy that's all that
matters to me well how am I feeling this
way more supposed to be happy for you
why does it feel like my heart is
splitting in half hurts so much
everything hurts so much
this would be so much better if I could
just disappear oh come on
Sara don't say that it's true more if I
wasn't here then you wouldn't have to
waste your sympathy on me you wouldn't
have to put up with me being selfish
Monica was right I should just what
Monica Monica was right about what yeah
say Ari
what I said before is true I'm not gonna
let this continue caring about you like
this isn't the burden your mind is
making it out to be it's something that
makes me happy it's something that I
wouldn't trade for anything else so even
if it takes an entire lifetime I'm gonna
be by your side until you don't feel any
more pain what's that's quite a group
that's quite a statement to make but
Sarah looks away I put a hand on her
shoulder to reassure I'm scared more
really scared what are you scared of
Siri I'm scared that then I might like
you more than you like me
say Orry it's true isn't it I was weak
and started to like you too much I did
this to myself
Marc I like you so much that I want to
die oh that's how I feel and that's
enough say Orry I don't want you to hurt
anymore I slide my hand down sailors arm
and squeeze her hand in my own do you
remember how I said I always know what's
best for you do you still believe me in
that rather egotistical statement that I
just said wordlessly saiary nods even if
you don't understand all of your own
feelings I know that you need the most
right now I know what you need the most
that's what I'm gonna give you what am I
gonna give you you'll always be my
dearest friend just say Orry well I like
you better than Natsuki I like you
better than Yuri I love ya I love ya
love ya love you rose I'll be terrible
alright my god I love you that seems
like right cuz I really thought like
Natsuki all that much I love you I love
you yeah
those are my true feelings so there's no
way you could make me like you like me
more than I like you I should have
realized it sooner but spending time
with everyone at the club making new
friends and having fun with you every
day it helped me realize that you are
truly the most important person to me
that's why I'll accept any of your
burdens as long as we can continue this
everyday with you by my side then I know
we'll both be happy orb suddenly Siri
wraps her arms tightly around me or is
this really okay yeah held saiary in my
arms and Buller closer you'll never have
to let go of me again I love you more I
want to be with you forever
me too but we're both in high school so
you know college whatever anyway I feel
say always grip around me weakened a
little bit what is this C or E I'm
supposed to be happy right now
I always thought this would be the
happiest moment for me but why even now
why won't the rain clouds go away
they're not going away at all morp it's
okay Siri might take some time for
things to get better again but no matter
how long it takes I'll be there every
step of the way that's all that matters
right now okay I trust you Siri and I
slowly release each other so I guess
that makes it festival tomorrow our
first date huh hey what are you saying I
don't want to think about those things
you know want everything to be the same
as it always has been even if we really
are a couple I don't know if I could
handle anything more right now it's
really new and scary to me
I understand we'll go at whatever pace
suits you best
hey more serieses at me once again
smiling sadly even if I get really
really sad this is the best thing for me
right yeah I don't really understand
what Sarah means by that are you saying
that this is making you feel sad C or E
I don't know I don't understand what I'm
feeling feels like a bunch of thorns
when you told me you loved me that's why
I want to trust you you know what's best
for me yeah I do that's my promise I say
that but in reality I've never sell more
uncertain when it comes to C or E I know
that I love her and she loves me but I'm
having as much trouble understanding
serious feelings as she is even though I
can comfort her I keep wondering if I
should be doing something more something
different I know these thoughts will
continue to plague me until things are
back to the way they were
is that what C or e meant by not wanting
anything to change I don't know but I
know that I'll give it everything I got
Sarah is the most important person to me
I'll do whatever it takes to have a
happy future with her oh it's a day of
the festival well alright then I'm gonna
add in this episode here cuz I'm gonna
wrap my head around everything that just
happens so thank you everybody so much
for watching I don't know what's going
on I don't know what's going on but it's
obvious right now that Monica is pulling
some strings behind the scenes that much
is very readily evident and I don't know
why to what end but I think we're gonna
find out in the next one so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye